to make any change in any aspect of your
life it has to start with offloading you
need to put something out of your brain
just to free up the space to just like
reflect to just think the second brain
is for the jobs that Google and
Wikipedia can't do what is the
population of France that's Google's job
what Google can't do is more subtle
questions questions that are unique to
you when you can see the data that makes
up your life in external form you can't
help but have insights about who you are
and and what you want all right guys
bang bang I'm here with Thiago uh I
first came around to this idea of
building a second brain and when I saw
it I thought it had something to do with
robotics aura or automation I was like
oh of course they're going to take uh
bring computer or interfaces and they're
going to put them in our brains and
we're all going to be cyborgs running
around uh and then I clicked
and realized that no this was much more
about productivity note-taking and kind
of systemized organization which in some
ways is almost more interesting for the
average person how did you come around
to realizing that this was going to be
something that you personally needed
right because I think that like you use
the system and now you're out teaching
other people how exactly they can do
this yeah yeah you know this the the
term second brain came much later but
years before I had that that term that
name it was a medical condition it was a
debilitating uh pain and tension in my
throat in my neck that started one day
when I was 22 out of the blue there was
no cause no reason that I could ever
determine uh and it just slowly got
worse over weeks months and then years
ultimately leading to like this
all-consuming pain
um that was just like the darkest
hardest period of my life and so I first
started taking notes because I was
seeing all these doctors and all these
different Specialists and they were
telling me all these different things
sometimes contradictory sometimes things
that I had to go research and learn
about sometimes things I had to try
right like little experiments
um the medication I was taking actually
affected my cognition and my memory so
like this is the crazy thing about
your body the very moment that I needed
to intake and make sense of all this
information my mind was at its lowest
point it was this contradiction and so I
just had to externalize I had to offload
all of those notes all of those all that
data to First paper and then paper got
unmanageable at a stack like this thick
I started doing it on the computer and
over a long period of time I started
using that same system of note-taking
for my studies to do my writing to
manage my productivity and eventually to
start a business so what's fascinating
to me about this whole thing is uh
there's a lot of science that I've read
uh if you write things down you will
remember them better right which uh if
you're reading you take notes there's
better recall there's better better
memory
but I don't think that you're actually
going through this process helping
people build these systems so they can
remember the information
um it seems more of that you want to
build a second brain or a database full
of the information that means you don't
have to actually remember it and
therefore you can query it later is that
is that like a fair way to think about
that yeah so memory is the Gateway okay
memory is just the entry point because
and it's a great entry point because we
have just terrible memories as humans
that is one of the things that that
computers do already so much better than
we can ever do right like what can the
human brain remember like five to seven
digits of a phone number at most
um and so you start there you offload I
mean just details your calendar how
useful is it to have a calendar your
to-do list your notes from meetings and
from calls your notes on books it's like
a simple like external storage medium
but once you start doing that
that's just the beginning because once
you've offloaded weird things start to
happen like for example you can notice
patterns when it's all that information
is outside of your brain you can look at
it you can evaluate it you can think
about it you can share it with others
get their feedback you can move it
around you can annotate it you can add
images and eventually it it starts with
memory but it becomes a creativity
enhancer productivity enhancer gives you
insights gives you profound Revelations
like when you can see your life
data that makes up your life in external
form you can't help but have insights
about who you are and and what you want
yeah I think it's David Allen I saw a
quote in one of your pieces where he
said uh your brain is for having ideas
yes not for holding them I thought that
was such a powerful uh quote because
really we don't think of uh the brain as
having two different functions yes most
people you said hey what's your brain
probably about thinking yeah right but
actually your brain is the computer that
holds all of the information and memory
that you have and so do you see a uh um
kind of an unlock by being able to kind
of kick out all of the uh memory and
information saving capacity to the
second brain does that free up kind of
your original brain for more creativity
more thinking more idea generation I I
absolutely think it does I think it's
interesting unlock is the I think I
might have that in the subtitle the word
unlock it's like it's this interesting
thing where you know I'm in the world of
like like you could call it self-help
advice self-improvement
and there's so much good advice out
there on anything anything you want to
improve your health you know your
relationships the way you think your
money endless advice and much of it is
quite good but it's like the average
person is so underwater
they have so little bandwidth there's
like no bandwidth left you can't even
make a change you can't even adjust how
you're doing things if you are at 110
capacity so one way I think of it is
like to make any change in any aspect of
your life it has to start with
offloading you need to put something out
of your brain just to free up the space
like you said to just like reflect to
just think to just have ideas until you
do that you are you know you're
underwater and you really can't consider
new options so it feels like uh I'm
starting to better understand this a
little bit there's like outside of your
brain there's just this flood of
information you're just constantly
bombarded with all this information then
right now people are doom scrolling or
or uh reading as much as they can every
article everything they just want as
much information as possible
but then they have to keep that in their
brain and that's what's almost like
clogging up and you don't have time to
stop think do all the stuff so really
what you're saying is like hey yes
there's all this information available
and even if you want to read it just go
ahead and keep kind of storing it away
in the second brain and then use the
brain that you have right now to think
exactly when you think of that
information kind of onslaught that we
all face every single day uh should
people be consuming all of that or do
you actually think part of it is like if
you just kind of sidestep or avoid all
of that that actually helps on the idea
generation creativity and kind of brain
processing uh if you will
yeah it's a great question so I think
so from all the information we're
consuming there's always a signal in the
noise right there's no way the by some
estimates 30 gigabytes of content that
you're consuming that you're exposed to
each day there's no way that's all
equally valuable there's I often use the
rule of thumb one percent there's the
one percent of all that information that
has the most value
so first of all it takes some
discernment you have to think about like
when you listen to say a two-hour
podcast what are the few quotes the few
ideas the few recommendations that
actually directly apply to your life now
but once you've done that that thinking
to discern what that is just save it
always be saving the one percent and
very quickly like in a matter of days or
weeks you're going to look at it's
almost this like library of knowledge
it's like a portfolio of thinking that
you've done that is totally unique to
you not one human being on the planet
has that same collection
and then you have a source to draw from
to create whatever you're creating
instead of doing what I think a lot of
people do which is terrifying sitting at
a blank page a blank screen and trying
to come up with a good idea which is the
recipe to to get nowhere yeah I do feel
like the more content you consume the
more ideas you have so I always joke uh
people will ask me
um hey you just tweeted like 20 times in
like two hours like what's going on I'm
usually reading right yes like I'm
consuming information now it's not uh
reading kind of garbage or I've seen you
talk about like Fast information is the
equivalent of fast food yes right like
pretty bad for your brain pretty bad for
your body this is higher quality
information uh at least supposedly it
somebody put in a book the book got
published right it's popular in many
cases
um and so what it does is then it
triggers thoughts for myself
[Music]
so how do you kind of balance between
like avoid all information versus like
do you just seek out the most important
or highest quality information like kind
of what's your day-to-day uh kind of
information consumption habits look like
yeah so um one way to measure that is
how many notes I take I actually
calculated this because I've been doing
this for over 10 years I just went in
and count you know tells you how many
notes you have divided by you know 10
years and I take on average over a long
period of time 2.1 notes per day okay
now 2.1 nodes how many over a decade we
are talking about probably five thousand
six thousand almost ten thousand maybe
right I think it would I think it might
approach or exceed ten thousand but then
I also delete them
so I'm at I'm at a little over 7 000
currently okay why do you delete nodes
that you've taken
so this is the interesting thing is
even of the notes that you decide oh
like how often in the moment you know
you're watching some video or whatever
and you're like oh this is so good and
then you come back later you're like
actually that was like clickbait that
sounded good in the moment it sounded
like so so wise but then when you just
think about it for like five seconds
you're like that actually doesn't mean
anything it's like completely empty uh
notes give you that feedback mechanism
so usually once a week approximately
maybe sometimes once every two weeks
I'll go in look at the notes I've taken
which at two notes per day would be what
14 notes every week or 28 every two
weeks that's a fine that's a reasonable
number when I say a note I don't mean
like hundreds or thousands of words it
could be one quote it could be one photo
it could be one thought or a few bullet
points they're very short they're
Snippets
once I do that it's a feedback mechanism
because I see what actually stands the
test of time which then goes and I
delete them if they're not useful that
feeds back into what I choose to consume
in the first place because I just I have
data I know what ends up being useful
over the long term and how that plays
out is I tend to read more books tend to
read more old books tend to read books
or other sources on fields that are not
my own I tend to more and more I find
myself going towards obscure sources I
find if I just consume all the same
best-selling whatever that all my peers
are consuming I tend to have the same
ideas so I actually have a I have a
subreddit that I started called obscure
PDFs if someone wants to know like
specifically what I recommend reading
you can look it up has a few thousand
members and it's like have you ever like
been past like a PDF by a friend it
looks like it's from like the 1970s it's
like photocopied it's like from some
like Department of Defense research team
that no one has ever heard of that tends
to be the best stuff because it stood
the test of time by being passed as a
PDF from person to person those are the
kind of stuff kind of things I like
these days and so if you're reading what
we'll call high quality information you
know day in and day out uh I guess the
first question is just like how many
hours a day right you you have a
business you you have a family you do
all these other things like are we
talking an hour a day do you carve out
like six hours a day on your calendar
and you just sit down and you just read
and everyone's jealous of you like how
do you actually uh interact on an uh our
spaces
yeah that's a good question
um not much at all especially these days
you know
a few years ago I think there was one
year I read like 50 books in a year
which was like my high water mark but I
I don't even know if I recommend that I
was just like force feeding myself you
know when I think back how much of those
books do I really remember it's
relatively little
um these days you know I have a team
like you said a family a household
um probably at most
an hour a day across podcasts which I
listen to like when I'm walking the dog
like multitasking like right like
walking the dog washing dishes driving
in the cars podcasts uh if I get a
little reading done like 30 minutes of
reading in the evening it's like kind of
a miracle uh and then of course like
during my work day like I'll just catch
little Snippets of of different you know
kinds of content yeah the other piece of
this is when you're reading what is your
process so
um I've told a story before that uh I
used to do everything audiobooks like
and I was obsessed and 2x and like you
know game on uh and I P somebody gave me
a physical book it was very hard for me
to read my eyes hurt I couldn't
concentrate like I was just like oh this
is bad so I've only been reading
physical books this year for the most
part
um and one I found like a renewed sense
of really enjoying reading uh for
whatever reason and then two is while I
read I sit and if I see something I like
I highlight it and I just keep reading
and then when I'm done with the book
I'll go back and I've got a couple
little tips and tricks that I'll try to
actually extract those highlights from
the book and then try to compile right
now it's very rudimentary notes but
aspirations to make it much better what
is your process when you're reading a
book or obscure PDF or anything like
that
yeah so today's episode is brought to
you by Alto I all right have you wanted
to buy Bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with Alto Ira
they allow you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantage way
there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to Alto ira.com to get started
Alto ira.com
invest in Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies Alto ira.com slash
it's pretty simple
um similar to yours I think that one of
the main principles is I really try to
separate reading from note taking
interesting like there's some advice out
there to read with a notebook right
there and so you read a passage and then
you like write it in your own words or
you like reflect on it or you write down
a passage that you want to save there's
very limited circumstances say like if
I'm reading like I don't know a
scientific paper or I'll do that but
usually it's so important that I get
that enjoyment
that enjoyment is what makes us
sustainable you're not going to do
anything that you don't enjoy for very
long and so the key to making it
enjoyable is to stay in flow for me and
so that means that the most that I do is
make a highlight like a digital
highlight I'm usually reading digital
books either on my Kindle which I carry
with me everywhere I have one right here
on the corner of the desk or if I don't
have my Kindle I can read the Kindle app
on my iPad or even my phone you know
like half the time I'm on my phone like
everyone else I'm reading books it's
kind of like amazing that you can
synchronize your progress on all these
different devices
um and then I use a service called read
wise do you know read wise uh I've heard
of it I used a different one but I think
they're the same yeah read wise is an
essential I mean it's so crucial crucial
crucial to all this because it just
works in the background I never have to
think about it mess with it I don't have
to go in and sync anything it just
listens or sort of detects any highlight
I make not just in ebooks by the way
eBooks on any device but articles like
blog posts online articles and then it
extracts just that text while keeping
track of the location and which book
it's from or which article it's from
saves it in my notes which I use
Evernote and so I basically have through
no additional effort besides just
reading and highlighting this compendium
of like several hundred books every
single little passage and idea that I
found interesting now you said you carry
Kindle everywhere you go why
so I eat for a long time for years I
would just read on the Kindle app on my
iPad I find since the start of covid my
and and also that coincided with having
my first kid with my wife uh Lauren uh
my attention span having Twitter on the
same device makes it not viable for me
anymore and so you're carrying it and
you'll kind of try to steal a couple
minutes here and there where you can
read and so having it with you always
means that you're kind of ready to go
exactly I need the dedicated reading
environment that doesn't have Twitter on
it helps that it's black and white
there's no color there's no fancy
graphics and I think the key is like I
like to measure how how many seconds
does it take you to continue where you
left off right a phone is fast look at
it unlock you know swipe up go over to
the app open and you're there but it
kind of even faster you just hit that
one button it says loading and you're
back to the exact point that you left
off that's important and when you
highlight in the Kindle we'll read wise
pull it into your notes or do you need
to take it from Kindle and then put no
it's totally automatic yeah within a few
minutes of any highlight that I make it
just appears magically in my notes it's
pretty incredible it's amazing so when
we think of the notes uh app you
mentioned the used Evernote there's I'm
gonna say a million I don't know maybe
less maybe there's actually more than a
million note taking apps at this point
um why Evernote because that's one
that's been around for actually a really
long time it's not one of the newer ones
is it just uh institutional uh kind of
debt of having used it for a long time
partially or is there something that in
your opinion uh it works better for you
than maybe other platforms yeah this is
one of the very controversial topics in
the second brain Community oh
interesting okay it's very controversial
um so you're right there's so many I
mean and this is this is it's an
opportunity but it's kind of a problem
um you know there's at least at least a
dozen major contenders that are like
kind of check all the boxes that you can
you can pick from besides Evernote you
know notion
um newer ones like obsidian Rome one's
made by the big tech companies Microsoft
OneNote Apple notes Google keep they're
all options
uh a couple reasons that I use Evernote
are just like you said Legacy like they
were really the first note-taking app to
use this term second brain actually I
should credit them for that
it was the first note-taking app that
wasn't just oh a little grocery list a
few bullet points your to-do list it was
like no you're creating a lifelong
treasury of knowledge they were the
first ones to have that long-term
perspective
um I've been with them for 10 years so
at this point it's like I will for sure
move at some point because there tends
to be these Generations like a whole new
wave of Technology comes along uh but an
interesting result of the second brain
thing that I that I often find is
because we're linking all these
different apps together we're routing
data from one to the other you have to
kind of be not at the Forefront of
Technology
you know like when a new kind of
Technology let's say tick tock comes out
can't if
you do what I'm describing things have
to be mature you know apps have to talk
to each other they have to use standard
formats there has to be some stability
and predictability so I often joke that
I like to be 10 years behind at the
Forefront right so Evernote you know 10
years ago was the popular app probably
in three to five years I'll adopt kind
of the new generation but I like to stay
on platforms basically to sum it up that
are mature stable and predictable yeah
and when you are in Evernote what are
you doing in there right so are you just
writing words and each kind of node is
separate from each other are you
actually uh connecting them in some way
is there uh something that you're
optimizing for search like there's a
whole bunch of stuff that you could do
uh and we don't have enough time for you
to explain kind of the entire system but
give people an understanding of like if
I write on a piece of paper that's a
dumb note right like these are like
smarter notes just by nature of being in
technology but how do you think about uh
the structure of the notes that you're
taking
yeah so there's different ways you can
approach this I really like to think of
it in terms of projects
there's been periods where I
you know I went in and I kind of nerded
out about structure about organization
created all these links these beautiful
data graphs you know these deep
hierarchies of Sub sub and subfolders
and over time just because I've been
doing this so long that stuff tends to
pass away like that stuff you're excited
about it for a few months and then you
kind of like Get over it and so I really
just think about like what am I trying
to achieve what is the information that
I need at my fingertips to achieve that
and then I will use some like linking
tagging adding uh even links to the web
some annotations some even tables and
kind of more sophisticated features but
the way that I hold myself accountable
to like actually being productive not
just like making it like a fun little
game and hobby is to focus on the
execution the completion of projects
when you mentioned having information at
your fingertips for something you're
working on when do you say I need a
piece of information and you go to
Google versus I need a piece of
information and you go to your notes
like that to me is uh at the most basic
difference it's like
content or information that's out there
versus things that are in my notes like
what derives where you go when you're
actually working on something
it's a it's a fantastic question and
honestly sometimes people become
overzealous with this and they try to
like recreate Google or like recreate
Wikipedia
you shouldn't do that
no no no no
um in a way a good question to ask is
the second brain is for the jobs that
Google and Wikipedia can't do
so as a simple example if you want to
know a fact like straight up facts what
is the population of France that's
Google's job like you can find that in a
fraction of a second any any answer if
you have a simple question it has a
simple answer
what Google can't do what Wikipedia
can't do is more subtle questions
questions that are unique to you
questions that don't have pre-defined
answers or even predefined questions one
way to think of it is like search on the
web is very top down you have a thing
you're looking for you may not know
exactly how to word it you may do like
several searches in a row but you have
some sense of where you're going You're
like drilling down from a something
you're trying to find to the answer your
second brain is bottom up
so you're saving things there that I
always say don't use your logical mind
that's for Google
pay attention to what resonates with you
what moves you what makes the like
physical Sensations are the best
indicator what makes the hair stand up
on your arm what makes your pupils
dilate what makes your sense of time
slow down what makes your heart be
differently it's like what those things
are is your body your intuition telling
you hey I'm reading this passage and
it's sparking something subconscious in
me that I can't quite put my finger on
that's the best thing to save because
over time if you save those things
I don't know how to explain it except
that patterns emerge insights emerge out
of the collection of things that you're
saving that you would never guess you
could never search for on Google because
it's Unique to you and that's your
competitive advantage over time what do
you do with those insights because I I
think that that's definitely true if
you're taking a bunch of notes you'll
start to connect things what do you do
with them make projects out of them okay
so this is a common misconception is
projects as I Define them can be top
down or bottom up sometimes your boss
says hey you need to do this that's a
top-down is just being given to you but
often projects are bottom up they emerge
like most of my writing happens this way
I don't have like a queue of like the
next 10 things I'm going to write on the
blog that would be so boring to just
like churn them out instead I just look
at my life I pay attention to signals
and patterns and then it's kind of like
when I start getting excited about
something you know and that feeling of
like you're you're you're discovering
something and then you start to notice
it everywhere you start to see examples
and everything you look at that to me
Sparks them a project which is a project
can simply many of my projects are just
be a piece of writing you know something
that I'm I'm sitting down and
synthesizing all these diverse thoughts
I think the important thing is to get it
out into the world you mentioned earlier
um that you spend a lot of time reading
things that are older and I've seen you
talk about this idea of relevance Decay
which I think a fascinating concept uh
explain what that means and and why is
it so important in today's day and age
when you kind of have that information
overload that's happening with maybe
things that are you know a high degree
of relevance decay
yes yes so I think
um one of the most useful metaphors for
information is food there's many many
parallels to food and
we can talk about that separately if you
want but one of the interesting
implications if you accept that analogy
is that information is perishable
information has a shelf life
it's not commonly understood we think of
information as as sort of Timeless oh
let me just stash this these gigabytes
of data on my hard drive it's there
forever until you know the world ends
and it gets destroyed but not really
information pretty much all information
has a it has a time limit right it has a
period in which it's relevant a period
in which it's not widely known right
like once that's the other thing with
Google anything you can access on Google
cannot be the source of your competitive
Advantage because everyone else has
access to it by definition
so what that this this idea that
information decays it goes bad what that
gives you
is the impulse to put it out there and
this is where Twitter comes into play
writing online right like like sometimes
I'll talk to people they're like I've
been doing research for three years on
this topic oh cool what have you
published what Have you shared no no I'm
just compiling the world's greatest
research database and it's just like no
you're not until you test it you
validate it you actually see what the
public or not even the public one other
person has to say you don't know if any
of that information is is useful it's
also a magnet like I do think there's a
lot of folks who I don't tell people my
ideas because somebody's going to take
it like like that whole uh mentality
pretty well uh disputed at this point
but for these people who uh maybe are
obsessive or perfectionists and they're
like I'm gonna write something but I
want it to be perfect yes
part of what they start to understand is
when you put something out you're
actually like putting bait in the water
right yeah and then guess what happens
all the people who are interested in
that bait they just come flying right
and they find you
um and so in some way one of the fastest
ways to learn is to put more and more
information out into the world and then
you will attract certain types of people
who you can learn from you can get up to
speed they can make recommendations like
and you're Off to the Races totally
totally you can think of a second brain
as just the preparation for that you
know like some people have some
hesitation understandably to just go
straight on Twitter and just like input
their direct thoughts
it helps to have just one stage of sort
of like curation you know like do a
brainstorm of 10 ideas and then tweet or
otherwise share one or two like the best
ones so in a way like a second brain is
like for recovering perfectionists who
need a little bit of preparation but I
still always encourage them get those
ideas out into the world as soon as
possible you mentioned earlier that uh
you're part of the self-help group uh
I'm a group I don't know the industry
whatever you want to call it I would
have said that you're part of the
productivity uh group or industry those
two things may be the same or they may
not how do is there a difference between
those or is one like a subcategory of
another does it even matter
yeah so self-help is like the least
charitable version
got it okay but it's all this I mean
what is the difference productivity
advice business advice entrepreneurship
advice in every case someone itself is
trying to help themselves
um but I kind of like using self-help
just to be a little provocative like
like let's reclaim that term like this
is this is kind of like one of my one of
my bones to pick is like yeah okay some
self-help is scammy some of it is is not
very useful but like it's people trying
to help themselves like let's not let's
not be down on that like that's one of
the most admirable you know qualities
there are so I'm kind of on a personal
mission to reclaim the self-help name I
love I love that I love that what are
some of the other productivity hacks
that you have right whether they're
actual hacks or they're things that you
do if you kind of think through your day
uh what are some of the things that
you've done where you're like these
really unlocked uh my productivity or my
potential
yeah you know they tend to to sort of
all be
it's interesting it's like you can think
of your second brain as the place where
you implement all the productivity hacks
right most productivity hacks they're
trying to get you to to make your first
brain your biological mind work
differently that is so hard it's so hard
to just decide okay Brain Change you
pretty much just think the way you think
you are the way you are like sorry but
that's very different with your second
brain you can change things you can go
and completely reorganize it you can go
and Implement entire new strategies new
tactics far more easily your second
brain essentially is far more malleable
than your first brain
um so you know I'll just give a few
examples things like morning journaling
you know many people do this millions of
people but I do it in my second brain in
my notes so that I can revisit it most
people don't have their their journaling
which to me is like these kind of
profound personal insights in a place
that it can be searched it can be
Revisited uh things like always keeping
my to-do list outside of my head keep
that somewhere outside right like a like
a notepad or a digital note things like
always saving my highlights when reading
things like collecting feedback that I
get from people that I respect and
saving it somewhere I tend to like in a
funny way self-help is about optimizing
your first brain I don't want to
optimize my first brain I just want to
be like a kid I just want to be free and
roam around and do stupid stuff and just
and just follow my Curiosities and
desires I don't want to optimize this
you know but there's certain
responsibilities and things I have to
get done so I optimize my second brain
so my first brain doesn't have to be
yeah when you do like the journaling and
you go back what are you looking for
patterns like
like think about here's an interesting
thought experiment so what you're doing
right now your interests your Pursuits
how far back when you look in the past
did they start when was the first little
glimmer that that was going to be
interesting for you do you have any
sense of that I have no clue so we
usually can't remember yesterday that's
why you need a journal right so so most
people say years it's like you know I
was interested in you know I don't know
um
you know cryptocurrency way back in 2013
or whatever I only finally got into it
in 2018 but usually there's these little
Clues way way early on
I think journaling is a way of detecting
those kind of emergent interests sooner
which obviously I mean in the case of
crypto like if you just noticed that you
were interested in that a little bit
earlier there were huge benefits
um it's self-awareness it's basically
system it's a systemized way of being
more self-aware
and
systems when you actually look at them
what are the downsides like the
productivity gains the unlocking of
creativity the memory and kind of
information recall like all that it's so
obvious right are there downsides
there's pitfalls I would say Okay
depending on how you do it so
yeah so some fitfalls one is getting
obsessed with which app you use you
wouldn't believe people spend months
years trying to decide which software to
use really oh yeah oh yeah and it's very
tribal you know like the notion fans
notion is one of the apps that people
use they're like they're like
antithetical they're like the enemies of
like the Rome tribe which is like
against the Evernote tribe like people
get like there's serious flame Wars yeah
it sounds like crypto exactly it's very
similar which kind of points to another
another Pitfall it becomes an ideology
sometimes which app or even which
technique which philosophy some people
swear by links oh no you have to have
the more links the better some people
swear by tags other people buy folders
some people insist that it has to be top
down and planned other people insist it
has to be bottom up and emergent there's
all these different schools of thought
one thing I'm trying to do personally is
like be this like ecumenical like let's
gather all the churches
bring them together and actually see
that we have common ground you know my
book is platform agnostic people have
used I think something upwards of 30
different apps to implement what I teach
which to me shows there are some common
principles and it's not like the biggest
decision in the world which app you use
do all of the apps use text as like a
base like that is one commonality is
that you can write text in all of them
you can write text in all of them but
there's two big groups the tech Centric
ones and the imagery Centric ones
interesting they tend to be quite
distinct explain that difference a
little bit more so all the ones I've
mentioned are text Rome obsidian notion
simple Note One Note Google keep they're
just specialized to text but then
there's this whole other school of
thought uh that has largely Arisen
around the iPad and the apple pencil so
there's one called millinote that is the
same thing but largely used by designers
there's notability like ones where you
actually open a canvas and draw that's
very different from like importing
little you know Snippets of text and
they consider like drawing notes because
you're uh in essence drawing what you're
thinking about what you're looking at so
if you're a visual and artistic which I
am not uh then uh that could be quite
helpful compared to just the text based
yeah it's almost like there's a spectrum
of like notebooks with lines over here
to sketchbooks think about a Sketchbook
that's just the digital version of a
Sketchbook yeah and
it's fascinating because it gets back to
like how people learn a little bit yes
and it feels like there's a connection
between how you learn and maybe how you
take notes because in some way uh notes
are you teaching your future self yes
right like I love that I don't know
what do you think I've in the book I say
it's communicating with your future self
but I like what you just said better
that's an improvement it's communicating
yeah
because I guess what you're really doing
is you're like leaving information that
your future self will discover and what
you're hoping is that it will trigger
either a memory an Insight or something
like that exactly you're teaching you're
preparing you are you're enriching your
future Life by the notes you're taking
now absolutely is there a difference
between physically writing them down
versus typing them do we know is there
any studies or anything of uh uh whether
one's better or the other for like
retention or how we think about that
there are most almost all the studies
say that paper note-taking is superior
interesting I take major issue with this
though okay it's like anytime there's a
paradigm shift like even like in science
the new thing is not mature enough to be
studied it's not mature enough to even
know what it's for right so all these
studies are taking for granted that the
paper style of note-taking is better and
then they're evaluating the two based on
those criteria it's absurd right so like
like one example is they say writing
words or writing notes in your own words
is superior for recall and retention
versus say copying and pasting them into
digital notes okay in isolation of
course that's true but it depends what
you do with those highlights if they
become part of a bigger creative
workflow where you are not just
rereading them but revisiting them
remixing them improving them and having
them become part of creative projects I
think that's Superior it's just kind of
hard to study that whole that whole
workflow yeah because they're basically
just saying like if you you put it on
physical paper you're going to have to
write letter by letter every single word
you're going to have you know kind of
the sketched into your brain yes versus
if you're just copying and pasting you
didn't actually write word for word yes
and therefore it was a shortcut which
then they believe is uh inferior and and
in isolation that's true but it's
missing the bigger context I wonder if I
was reading a physical book I
highlighted something and then at the
end I went and I typed uh word for word
what the highlights were if that would
have the same retention as if I wrote it
by hand
could be right so rather than copy and
paste if I actually typed out the nodes
it could be and it's pretty similar
right yeah yeah it's a thing it's so
this is the other thing it's not either
or nothing in this world is either or
you can I mean OCR optical character
recognition is so good even your hand
right your messy handwriting you can
take a photo of with one of these
note-taking apps and it will capture
what you've written so like I do both
kinds of note taking depending on the
situation there's some clear situations
paper is superior other situations
digital Superior I really just try to
use them both yeah when you're going
through your day uh obviously we talk
about reading taking notes
um you talked about a journal are there
other things that you write down uh
to-do list what how do you operate with
a to-do list
that's what David Allen called open
Loops often most of the time the things
you have to do
just arise like at the most random times
like you're in the elevator you know
you're in the shower you're driving in
the car so I just try to have a place
and I use actually a dedicated app for
this called a task manager like a
digital to-do list app
um to just write those things down and
then once a week I go back and actually
decide which of those things actually
needs to get done
um so you're just writing down the ideas
as they come to you in this digital task
manager is that the name of the one you
use or it's called things things very
very absent name
um and so as you're writing these down
you actually wait till the end of the
week to go look or will you every
morning wake up and say hey what do I
have to do today yeah so I followed
David Allen who you mentioned it has
really been my Prime inspiration my
whole career started um teaching his
system actually it's called GTD getting
things done uh I just follow exactly his
recommendations write it down when it
occurs to you so you don't forget it and
then yes so the interesting thing is you
know when an idea arises it's not clear
what it is
in the moment it's just it's just a
brain fart it's just something that
popped into your head so you write it
down and then later you come back to it
with some more distance some more
objectivity it could become a task it
could become a note it could become
something to send to someone it could
become just an idea for the future it's
like it's very powerful to separate the
capturing of something from the deciding
what to do with it yeah see
the things that I usually randomly get
outside of maybe like uh uh you know
business ideas or or things that I would
put in the idea category usually I'm
like oh [ __ ] I gotta do X and I've tried
a lot of things from uh all remember
a news flash doesn't work
um to his email myself and then I go to
my inbox and it's serving as like
there's there to do not great uh because
then sometimes it's more complex or
whatever uh to actually the number one
thing that I've seen work is a physical
note card and I just write down at the
beginning of every day whatever wasn't
done from the note card yesterday and
then throughout the day I just write
down on the note card anything that pops
up and I try to cross things off perfect
the problem is you can lose the note
card you can leave it somewhere right
you can uh leave it at home and get to
the office I go sure where's no car like
it's not as great
um and so maybe the digital you know
kind of note card form is you know
something like these apps that uh that
are better but I don't know if I could
write things down and then wait until
the end of the week only because the
things I'm probably writing down on the
to-do list are like more day-to-day
actionable yeah so what are you writing
down on your uh uh kind of to-do list
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
and eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep yeah so I capture it all
and then that once a week approximately
once a week I'll make like a this week
list things I want to get done this week
but I can also just add something
directly to the this week list or today
list it's not like I have to rigidly
follow each step
um often I'll go day is just interacting
with that this week list adding things
removing things editing things
what the weekly ritual is is a sort of
backup plan it's like a safety net
there's anything that completely fell
through the cracks I know at least once
a week more or less I'll sort of revisit
it but what you described is perfect I
think people really over engineer this
like what matters is that things get
done what doesn't matter is the way it
looks the way it's organized how
structured it is with you know the
colors all that kind of stuff is just is
just minor all right now we're going to
dig into the real stuff uh you have a
team of people yes that uh that you work
with can they add things to your to-do
list without you uh having to do it
absolutely not
although wait there's a caveat
okay
um so we use so my personal to-do lists
and things and things is totally
designed for individual use in fact
there's no sharing feature you can't
even if you wanted to you can't share or
be shared with it's almost like a silo
right which means I have to I have to
consciously decide whether something
goes on that list but we have a team
task management app uh that we use
called click up
that's the one for the team
um and that is managed by my head of
operations because she really has this
incredible you know architected system
in there I try to never go in there I
try to avoid it at all costs but things
can be assigned to me interesting so if
someone tags me and often you know the
most Junior person in the company often
they need something from me it's
understandable so they'll just tag me I
will get an email notification saying
this person has assigned this to you but
then I can I can add that in the way
that makes sense to me right like often
they'll be asking for a decision but in
order to make that decision I have to do
three things so then I'll put those
three things on my to-do list then when
I'm done I'll just I can actually reply
to the email and say done and in the
system in the cloud it will it will Mark
that off as done without me having to go
in and do that yeah so it's pretty
interesting where like they can
essentially tag you it then gets a sign
you do what you want with it and then
when you're done you can let uh uh the
system and that person know exactly now
when you think of
um kind of note taking or building a
second brain you have built one for
yourself over a decade which is pretty
incredible do you do it for the team
each person has their own path okay it's
something I really emphasize so like
we're in the field of Knowledge
Management right it's sort of the
academic discipline
um in the past Knowledge Management was
only done by companies or teams because
they're the only ones who cared like no
individual really
um had enough volume of information
consumption that they needed something
like this
so over just the past like 10 years uh
it's gone from a corporate team thing to
an individualistic thing and in
companies and organizations it was very
top down you know some consultant would
come in hey everyone we're now doing a
knowledge sharing initiative you must
all share your knowledge input your
knowledge into this Wiki
which if you think about it is a very
Draconian thing to do like that's not
empowering that's in fact you could even
think of that as like taking away
people's power right like it's up to
them whether they want to share their
knowledge like your employer doesn't own
every single idea in your head they
don't they're buying your time not your
entire you know expertise and so I
resist in our company and even in our
clients I resist any top-down like
setting a policy instead each person
should be trained and supported to
create the system that works for them
and they look so different some people
have like five notes in Apple notes that
serves them perfectly other people have
like 10 000 nodes in Rome and that
serves them perfectly it has to match
your personality so I'll buy that uh
inside large organizations they have
wikis and all sorts of like the
institutional knowledge and I think the
thought processes if somebody new joins
uh they don't have to go around and talk
to every single person who's ever worked
at this company to get a bunch of this
information and
um in the large companies I'm thinking
of the wikis could be as simple as like
you know how to change your uh health
benefits or it could be how to add up or
subtract something from the product
right you know very very specific things
that you're going to need in this job
they also can be uh more documentation
of historical decisions hey we did this
this is why we did it uh and we're going
to revisit in two years to see you know
what's a good decision or not or
whatever do you guys have any sort of
like company Knowledge Management so if
you don't build a second brain for the
company like what do you what do you do
so when new uh members of the team join
or get onboarded where do they go
it's a great point so I would say there
is a role for you could call it
corporate Knowledge Management or group
Knowledge Management or shared Knowledge
Management
it's those use cases that you said uh
documentation checklists references need
to know uh background sometimes
technical information
um
so in a way the same way we asked okay
what jobs does Google do let's not try
to replicate those I would say what jobs
does the corporate Wiki The Company Wiki
do do use that for exactly the things
you described yeah but then think about
the limitations of that right all the
kinds of information you mentioned are
like very explicit they're very
structured they need to be structured
for people to make sense of them right
like no one can make sense of your
random like half-formed thoughts and
like bullet points it needs to be quite
formal in order to be understandable by
a group uh the second brain is for
everything else for knowledge that is
tacit knowledge that you maybe can't
even fully put into words knowledge that
is subtle knowledge that is emergent
knowledge that is private knowledge that
is specific to your job right that maybe
no one else needs to know
um so to answer your question we have
Sops
which stands for standard operating
procedures uh we're kind of Fanatics
about them everything that has to be
done more than once or more than a few
times how to publish a blog post how to
organize a local Meetup how to run one
of our class sessions how to book an
interview how to send an invoice has a
very detailed step-by-step checklist
really yes so take I don't know how to
book an interview right what it would be
in a document like that
like literally step by step like get the
person's email address use this template
on the email uh follow up after two days
if they don't respond like that level of
detail yes so it's funny I I'm not sure
these days exactly what's on it because
I haven't looked at it in so long but
um so
it tends to be in checklist format
because we're interested in the outcome
the actions right but it tends to be not
the exact steps because many of the
specific steps are obvious you could say
like
turn on your computer open the browser
like come on
if you're doing that you may have hired
the wrong person yes exactly you have to
you have to like assume a certain level
of competition and how do you uh check
the checklist if your computer's not on
also right true you have to plug it in
you have to wake up and put on clothes
[Laughter]
um but what what tends to be documented
there is things we've learned okay you
know like an interview I have learned so
many little preferences I like to be in
this sort of conversational format not
that one I like to do it in the morning
not the afternoon I like to be an
informal close not some buttoned up suit
like basically every mistake I've made
becomes a little note in the SOP so that
we don't lose that you know that that is
basically institutional knowledge that I
don't want to have to remember in my
first brain uh and my assistant can just
go there know every single one of my
preferences and just execute it
how do you work with your assistant I'm
always fascinated by people who are
highly productive especially somebody
like you who you think about
productivity Knowledge Management all of
this stuff uh what is the um kind of
day-to-day uh interactions look like
yeah let's see
um it's pretty informal in fact our
whole when people join our company
they're often very surprised how
informal it is
um I think they see sort of my public
Persona which is all productivity and
checklist and all these things and they
think that that's who I am or something
like you know I'm like have a following
a checklist to brush my teeth I'm not
like that in fact the reason I want a
second brain that is pretty intentional
and organized is so the rest of my life
doesn't have to be like I said
so it's quite informal and I kind of
think it's it's much like most people
who have assistance work with their
assistants with maybe the one difference
that everything is documented so like
half the communication not only between
me and my assistant but on the whole
team is just sharing links and they're
links to notes really constantly
constantly give me an example yeah like
if someone uh so last night I organized
a local Meetup of followers here in
Miami
um that is not yet an sop because I
don't do it often enough
I wanted my assistant to just handle
that like a week ago so I just said
please Victoria can you organize a local
Meetup I just needed to tell her like
three inputs you know in Miami Tuesday
night some sort of restaurant where we
can get food and then I just sent a link
which was from my personal notes no
shared space my checklist that I
followed in the past of how to organize
a Meetup and she just had a couple of
follow-up questions and then the last
thing I asked her to do was okay this
seems to be something that we're doing
more often the last thing you do please
basically migrate this from thiago's
personal notes to the team database
interesting and so when she's going
through that process what happens if she
does something that works that's not in
the notes or vice versa she does
something that's in the notes and it
doesn't work do you
actively try to like upgrade or improve
the steps and and kind of processes or
how or is it more of a I violated the
system like an alarm goes off and like
yeah like trouble
no no one gets in trouble
no one gets in trouble I think that's
important because we're all just
learning like you said notes are
learning it's learning across time in a
systematic way
um I'm very interested in like learning
theory learning psychology the two
biggest ways to stop all learning is to
introduce guilt and shame
guilt and shame are the very antithesis
of of good learning
so no one gets in trouble it's just a
learning opportunity in fact this is
another thing that people are surprised
by when they join the company that is a
big part of our culture that they often
have to unlearn from other places
they've worked when we make a mistake
I'm happy
as long as you know it wasn't like pure
negligence like pure just didn't even
try uh we I just assume we did our best
or whoever did it did their best as long
as we can document the learning this is
the answer to your question like I'm
people people on our team just know that
I'm constantly saying people are in
collaboration in general people are
saying these little interesting tidbits
often in passing they'll be like oh yeah
we always find no no no or we we should
never do it and I'm always saying hey
what you just said that was good write
it down really yes so you spend a lot of
your time almost trying to reinforce the
write down the Insight yes a culture of
documentation you would think that our
company adopts that more than any but
it's it's not natural I think for humans
to cons it's almost like I try to live
like the guy in memento
every time I have an idea I might
remember it it may come up again but I
just assume that like tomorrow morning
my memory is going to be wiped and
actually
um back to my story of my health
condition one of the medications that I
took had like severe short-term memory
loss as one of the side effects whoa
yeah like like if we talked today I
wouldn't remember that we talked
tomorrow like almost literally wiping my
memory and so I had like a window into
this I had like a an experience of what
this is like when you expect nothing to
be remembered the second it occurs to
you you are reaching for a pen to write
it down
it just becomes a lifestyle and so you
just got reinforced over time you
mentioned that you're interested in
learning theory well tell me more about
that space
yeah I mean it's largely academic
um I mean our business is an online
course business we have one product
mostly uh which is a three-week
intensive program in a year-long
membership that people can join and so I
mean I'm immersed in learning theory
teaching Theory educational theory and
practice not just Theory all day long I
find it's one of these it's like
everything is learning now right like
like can you say when you're learning
and when you're not like in your dreams
you're learning one of the functions of
Dreams is learning you are literally
learning every minute you are alive
so I don't see learning in education as
this like little niche oh this thing I
did for four years in college I see it
as kind of just like how to live
effectively as a human being and learn
from your experiences and learning
theory itself is trying to get at like
what's the best way to learn and are
there any insights or takeaways that
you've had as you've studied some about
literature
as she learned about learning yeah
took notes on taking notes
so many things there's so many
counter-intuitive things like what
um I mean one that's that's becoming
more and more known is the role of
emotions emotions are just Central to
learning even in subjects that are
technical uh very left-brained
engineering it's all emotional learning
uh the importance of collaboration you
know social learning is not this like
one special kind of learning all
learning is inherently social there's
actually research that even in the
privacy of your mind the way you
actually digest Concepts is basically to
have one voice like one personality in
your head teach it to the other one
interesting you're having this how often
do you does it feel like you're having a
conversation in your head right it's
like even in the privacy of our heads we
are social Learners see you can say that
and people won't think you're weird if I
said oh I'm talking to myself in my head
people like oh pump's gone crazy so uh
I'll let you uh take that but I do think
um it's always funny to me like uh when
you're thinking you're really talking to
yourself right uh yeah and there is this
element of
um uh social aspect to it I think for
sure
yeah those are a couple I mean we can
get into this but
it's like basically the opposite of what
universities do
really yeah largely in what way like
what are some of the biggest differences
that you see uh or maybe the mistakes
that the universities are making
oh my gosh it's everything everything
from you know the the time gap between
when you learn something and when you
put it into practice
for universities it's unless you're like
performing an experiment in the lab it's
years you won't find out like you know
especially in fast-moving Fields like
marketing I took a marketing class in
college I didn't discover for about six
years
that it was not useful right
um everything to I mean this focus on
individualism it's wild that all our
learning
is done solo you can't look at any I
mean of course you can't look at
anyone's test you can't borrow from
anyone's essay you can't get help you
know at the most you can do a study
group but it's kind of like frown upon
and then you step out into the
professional world everything is
collaborative you don't do anything by
yourself all you're doing is looking at
other people's work and borrowing bits
and pieces and and models
um what else uh
I mean not having skin in the game like
there's a lot of evidence that your
personal degree of risk what is this the
skin you have in the game which relates
to your emotions you know are you
actually putting something on the line
has is a has a huge impact on on your
learning uh there's even things like
like this is one of the most kind of
Politically Incorrect things
which is this is one paper I I found
like a research study on this that for
True learning to happen there has to be
an external shock
interesting there has to be like the the
existing belief system that you have
which is really what you're trying to
change you always have some existing
understanding it is so resistant to
change it will not yield to any external
influence unless there is a shock
actual destabilization
which is so Politically Incorrect like
like think about how we design schools
everything's safe comfortable safe
spaces don't say anything trigger
warnings everything is made completely
safe and we're completely ignoring that
we as humans we basically don't change
until our environment becomes like
destabilized for lack of a better term
what are like a type of external shock
that would increase learning
yeah so so there's definitely you know
good kinds of shock yeah that's what I'm
getting at is like I I when I hear that
I'm like oh like should should we like
play really loud noises or so like
that's maybe the watered down version
versus like you know like I don't know
if you hit people while they're learning
do they learn fast like wait give me
some examples yeah so there's definitely
ways you should do it
um
what's interesting is
the parts of our brain and our body that
have to do with risk when we take say a
social risk from the perspective of our
body physiologically it's as if we're
taking a physical risk like our body
responds the same whether we're putting
an idea on Twitter that we're not sure
about or like fighting a lion maybe
maybe a difference in degree but
um and so it often comes down to that
like the course that I teach we do a
live
there's no there's no like show up and
watch videos on a website that's no skin
in the game you join a zoom call we ask
you turn on your camera unmute your mic
talk share reflect back what you just
learned to real human beings like right
after you learned it people are so
terrified by this you would think I'm
asking them to like jump over you know
jump over the Grand Canyon they will not
do it they are so scared of saying one
word in front of a group but then the
minute they do it's like oh there's this
huge relief and they always tell us that
that was the most transformative moment
it's so fascinating how many people
still don't like doing that stuff
they're terrified yeah and is it because
they're scared they're gonna make a
mistake they're gonna sound dumb they uh
they don't know the subject matter like
what do you find is the thing that is
driving that fear I think all the above
it's a new race car
Maybe
but actually no okay X is one of the
world's leading crypto trading apps okay
X
every bit of training in our educational
career is what don't make mistakes don't
take like don't take risks why would you
ever take a risk in your in not just
your educational career your
professional career we have a risk like
like bread out of us from kindergarten
as if like I call this the LIE of
professionalism this is like one of my
one of my bones to pick is like I talk
to professionals that have Stellar
careers they've worked at the most
prestigious companies they've had the
most prestigious titles they had this
idea that if they just never make a
mistake
they will have this incredible
trajectory of success they'll have the
life of their dreams all the goals they
want to achieve the money they want to
make that has never been true and is
becoming less and less true you have to
take a risk of some kind or else you're
just not you're not going to have those
things yeah
it feels like
um
the people who take risk kind of
self-select right they have a higher
appetite for risk obviously
but we could really like kind of [ __ ]
people up if uh We've forced them to
take risks super early on yeah and
one of the points in life that uh now
um I'm in my 30s uh a lot of our friends
and things that they're starting to have
kids and and think about where do we
want to live and like do all these
different things
I was talking to a woman yesterday and
uh she recently moved uh from another
major city I don't give any identifiable
information from another major city uh
to Miami uh and uh she works
um tangential kind of in a service
industry to the tech industry and her
husband uh works at a pretty large tech
company and she had her entire life uh
the goal to reach a certain point within
the organization she was in she reached
it and her husband had a goal
professionally and he reached it and
they were relatively young still and all
of a sudden her company called her and
said
would you like to move to Miami and she
was like No And they're like well you're
going to have all this more
responsibility like lately laid out the
opportunity and she was like
that is pretty attractive so she went to
her husband and she was like
this is the opportunity like what do you
think and his first reaction was like
why would we disrupt and risk
our life we've gotten like we dreamed of
getting to this position and we got it
right and it was really interesting to
talk to her kind of go through the
different details because ultimately
what ended up happening is it took not
just a single decision point it took
time for them to both get comfortable
with okay we aren't necessarily giving
up a lot in terms of the professional
goals we've achieved yes we like where
we live but maybe we'll like this other
place more like there was a a mind shift
a mindset shift that they had to go
through to actually look at it as a uh
potential another step in the journey
that they were trying to accomplish yes
rather than a step backwards or a side
step or something like that yeah so it
was pretty interesting to kind of see
like Risk almost uh when presented was a
a very abrasive thing yeah but then they
were able to essentially just say no
actually maybe this is just a bigger
opportunity and we need to look at it a
different way I think taking risks is
what makes you feel alive and you know
sometimes when I talk about this people
think what I'm referring to is
entrepreneurship I'm not that is just
one of a thousand ways to take risks
think about talking to a stranger
like sometimes like I'm an introvert I'm
kind of scared of strangers but I've had
some conversations with just random
people at bus stops and cafes that just
blew my mind opened me up to a whole
different point of view think about the
risk of moving to a different country
I've lived in I've lived in a few
different countries
those are my most precious experiences
basically which one was your favorite
Brazil Brazil yeah what was that my
family's from Brazil so it's kind of
kind of biased yeah what was that
experience like you were born in the
United States and then moved there yes
okay I've seen probably like
20 of my life in Brazil okay a big chunk
of it we go there like every year since
I was born uh it's just it's just a
parallel reality it's the opposite of
American culture it's like having a
black and white two parallel realities
that every time one starts to get
unbearable or annoying or I just don't
like it I can just like switch into the
other
that's pretty cool another way you
mentioned like talking to strangers like
I think a lot about uh people who ask
questions right and um over the years
I've gotten very comfortable asking like
really dumb questions but like I learned
uh that way and
um I remember I give you an example uh
well my wife had our daughter was in the
hospital I remember I went to the like
nurses station and I was very
um out of my element right I'm in a
hospital like I did not have a baby now
I have a baby like this was like a
pretty uh uh jarring thing and but I was
nervous because I was like I don't want
to screw up right and so I remember I
went to uh the nurse's station and I was
uh uh trying to kind of break the ice a
little bit so I was like who's the
LeBron James of swaddling
and the nurses were like what and I was
like who is the world's greatest right
and uh I don't want to get in the debate
of who's the best hospital player in the
world but I figured they probably knew
LeBron right and his house like who's
the LeBron James swaddling they're like
oh we'll we'll be there in a minute so a
woman shows up and like she pretty much
to me was LeBron James of swaddling but
while she was doing it I asked her why
did you do that why did you do that like
what about this like oh does it work
this way or you know how did you uh take
the towel and do this whatever
and I probably learned more in that you
know 10-minute experience than watching
100 YouTube videos right yeah and so yes
I was joking around and like trying to
be funny or whatever but
just literally asking like hey I don't
know how to do this like who can help me
uh it actually seemed easier in a moment
where I was like outside of my element
versus if I was sitting with a colleague
and I'm like [ __ ] I don't know how to do
this yeah people I think get the
protective a little bit Yeah of their
intelligence their their productivity
their position in the company like it's
actually easier in the hospital scenario
than it would be like you're in a
meeting at work or somebody just turned
like I don't know how to do this can you
show me seriously now that's a great
example risk uncertainty it's it's
present in every moment like even in in
conversations I'm here with my my little
brother uh we're 10 years apart I
brought into Miami a little vacation and
you know often your family members you
think you've talked about everything
it's like kind of the awkward silence
like okay well what do we talk about and
uh we were at dinner a couple nights ago
and I just had this idea hey I could
mention insert sensitive subject about
the family politics and I I could feel
the fear what is this going to bring up
like this is one of those things we
don't talk about but like it was such a
unique situation you know we're here on
a trip just the two of us which has
never happened and I was just I could
feel the fear like no I don't want to
just play it safe make small talk talk
about the food the weather anything but
I took that little risk okay like Marco
what do you think about X we sat there
for two hours unpacked this entire
chapter of our family's life it was the
most meaningful conversation I've had
with him in years yeah it was a risk
yeah and do you feel like in those
scenarios uh you've just learned just
jump every time or do you still catch
yourself sometimes be like ah it's a
risk actually that I should avoid
you know by by my nature I'm like this
is the thing you always teach the thing
you need
right you learn and master the thing
that you don't have originally
um by Nature I am like people don't
believe me when I say this but I am the
most risk-averse conservative socially
fearful introverted just person you've
ever met that is the like the op as a
kid if you saw me I was like hidden the
book don't talk to anyone don't go
anywhere don't do anything new I was
just in my own little world I basically
had to like develop this yeah by like
you said forcing myself to do it yeah
talk about asking questions I've seen
you talk about open questions
um what what is an open question
yeah this is one of the people's
favorite parts of the of my book
actually
um so I talked about projects which is
kind of a top-down concept I'm going to
create and execute a project
but sometimes you don't even know what
you're trying to do or find well enough
to make it a project or maybe you just
don't have the time and so
one of the big questions I help people
answer is like like in some sense the
most important question with the second
brain is like why why am I going to do
all this right it takes time it takes
energy what is the purpose and so one of
the exercises that I have them do in my
course is make a list of your open
questions what are the long-term
recurring questions that you find
yourself asking
and I the the key thing here is to not
have them start with do or did or is
which are like yes or no questions have
them start with how or what interesting
how or what questions cannot be answered
yes or no they require an explanation
some context and so by making this list
saving it you know pin it there to the
top of your second brain and then every
time you're out in the world and you
notice something that could potentially
answer one of your open questions write
it down that's like your filter what in
the world will help me make progress on
my open questions
it's such a uh a simple thing but so
powerful right if executed correctly
totally
um you wrote this book building a second
brain a proven method to organize your
Digital Life and unlock your creative
potential uh that's the title and
subtitle but my favorite part is just at
the top remember everything achieve
anything like I think that's ultimately
what everyone wants to do right they
want to remember everything and achieve
anything talk to me about actually the
process for writing the book
yeah yeah this has been I mean it's a
four-year project for four years yep
from very beginning to end was four
years
uh what do you wanna what do you want to
get into why did it take four years
great question yeah
um
so that's largely typical typical might
be like two to three years the reasons
it took four were a combination of uh
the pandemic uh moving right at the
start of the pandemic we moved from
Mexico City to the US also bought a
house had a kid and basically started a
life got married in that time so it's
basically life and then also the fact
that I was continuing to run the
business so I didn't have the luxury of
like going off and just writing a book
it was like manage all your usual stuff
and also write the book
um but uh
yeah really just from so I was
synthesizing really five years of
teaching this course uh into book form
it was just a reviewing a lot of notes
so a lot of sources a lot of research a
lot of iterations so the book is
interesting because
um I just opened up to a random page and
in two pages there's everything from uh
highlighting 2.0 the progressive
summarization technique which is like a
very specific uh thing it comes with a a
graphic and like shows you exactly what
to do right and kind of how to build
layers and do other stuff uh but also uh
on the other page it's how the brain
stops time and it talks about strange
side effects of intense fear is time
dilation the parents slowing down of
time survivors of life and death
situations often report that things seem
to take longer to happen
Etc and so this book is uh uh can be
very practical uh it can be very
academic and kind of everything in
between it almost feels is that
intentional or is that just kind of how
you think about the building of the
second brain is it actually takes
somewhat different and extreme ends of a
spectrum and it both are needed to be
able to do this successfully
I think it's both yeah it's um it's
definitely both
creating a system of Knowledge
Management which is what a second brain
is I think is inherently eclectic like
that's what you're doing you're just
collecting little chunks little bits and
pieces from papers you read books you
read podcasts you listen to from all
sorts of different fields from different
industries from different eras there's
no way that the the thing that ends up
at the end of that is not super diverse
and eclectic but I think my approach to
it is also eclectic from a combination
of being Multicultural multilingual you
know my dad is from the Philippines my
mom is from Brazil and we live in the
United States so this kind of like
inherent to my life but also it's like
we're creating something new here
previous generations of humans they had
things like commonplace books they took
notes but never before just like now did
people have to create centralized
databases for their knowledge that's
like a new thing
so there's not like you can't like go to
a university Hey where's the personal
Knowledge Management Department and just
like ask them it is a fusion it's an
intersection of many different fields
which is why I think it comes out that
way yeah it also
um I love the idea that it's personal to
you right like that to me feels like the
most important part here is
um I know some people uh um wearable
stuff is like a good uh example
I have friends who wear like six
different things they got the aura ring
they got the whoop they got the watch
they got the master like they got it all
right they're ready to rock and roll uh
I know other friends who uh are probably
more like me I wear an Apple Watch and I
like to be able to tell the time and
also it tracks things kind of passively
in the background right which is all I
need
um but then what do people do with the
data I'm always fascinated with and so I
literally have friends who build
spreadsheets and they track things and
like they are data nerds and then like
every once in a while I'll look at the
data uh maybe the most I interact with
it is actually like the Apple watch
notifications that get sent to me right
and yells at me like hey are you dead
right why are you not moving
um but but that seems a lot like the
second brain concept right some people
will be very very deep into the details
they'll go and they'll read everything
every day and they'll go and they'll
search and do all stuff and other people
may actually just do it as a way to
learn an inputting process and then
search you know randomly when they need
stuff exactly is that pretty much the
same thing so it's funny you mention
that because
um one of my main sources of inspiration
which is mentioned in the book is What's
called the Quantified Self movement
which is what you just described this
whole thing of measuring analyzing data
about yourself
um there was a period for a few years
when I lived in San Francisco I was like
deep in that Community I would give talk
some presentations I would like go to
the I went to the yearly conference I
was like a card carrying member of the
Quantified Self movement which is you
know measuring your your nutrition in
your exercise your sleep all these
things but it's funny because after
several years several years of that
it's like it's it's funny it's like yeah
you see all this data and you're like do
I actually understand myself better
and not really
what you always take away though is it
is the process of tracking it that gives
you the benefits there's no like you
don't see like one number like now I
understand like my whole life no but
there's still value in just the it's
like the the personal experience of
tracking automatically gives you
self-awareness and so what I took away
from that is you know building a second
brain is not very like data-ish it's not
very quantitative I'm more like on the
artist side of the spectrum than the
engineer right but similarly you are
self-documenting self-tracking
self-analyzing but you're doing it in a
more free form intuitive way with words
and images and metaphors and stories
rather than like a spreadsheet but it is
definitely very related yeah it it
um I never actually thought about the
the comparison there but it is pretty uh
pretty interesting where um where can we
send people to find the book and and
also to uh to look at the course that
you guys provide
they can find everything at building a
second brain.com we have all the places
you can buy the book which is available
in bookstores libraries pretty much
everywhere on its way to being
translated to 20 different languages wow
um they can find the course which is now
a year-long membership they can find our
podcast if they just want little
bite-sized episodes our blog a bunch of
free resources the whole second brain
universe is at building a
secondbrain.com awesome and then where
are you on uh on social media that
people can find you I am at Forte Labs
which is the name of the company that
produces all this that's
f-o-r-t-e-l-a-b-s for tailabs.com Forte
Labs on Twitter pretty much Instagram
pretty much everywhere awesome
um I I really enjoyed this uh I feel
like you are um kind of at the Forefront
of something that's going to become more
important over time
um and uh as we were talking I was
thinking to myself like uh today we find
it so fascinating that somebody goes on
an archaeological dig and they discover
some you know crazy remnants of some you
know historical land uh in some way the
second brain is uh the remnants of a
person's life right and and
um while there might not be
archaeologists that go and find them
um it is pretty interesting to kind of
see people build these out and as
technology improves I bet you there's
going to be some pretty interesting
things that people are going to be able
to do with this absolutely absolutely I
couldn't be more excited it's I think
it's the beginning of a big wave
that is the best place to be all right
thank you so much we'll definitely do it
again in the future really appreciate it